en su primer discurso ante la asamblea
general de la onu tras la crisis por el
retiro de afganistán y de los submarinos
de propulsión nuclear joe biden prometió
diplomacia implacable y moderación
militar discurso que también iba
dirigido a rebajar las tensiones con
china
defenderemos a nuestros aliados y amigos
y nos opondremos a los intentos de los
países más fuertes de dominar a los más
débiles pero no buscamos repito no
buscamos una nueva guerra fría en un
mundo dividido en bloques rígidos
aunque vaya de no mencionar china ni una
sola vez en su discurso de 34 minutos
sus palabras parecían ser una respuesta
al secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres que calificó las relaciones
entre eeuu y china de completamente
disfuncionales ya advirtió que podrían
dirigirse a una nueva guerra fría el
presidente chino también eligió un
lenguaje tranquilo
tenemos que buscar el diálogo y la
inclusión por encima de la confrontación
y la exclusión
by then trató otros temas importantes de
actualidad internacional prometió doblar
la financiación la lucha contra el
cambio climático dijo que están
dispuestos a volver al pleno
cumplimiento del acuerdo nuclear con
irán si desde teherán hacen lo mismo y
también habló de medio oriente y la
necesidad de un estado palestino para
solucionar el conflicto con israel
además de otros conflictos vigentes como
el de corea y etiopía
no podemos permitirnos perder más tiempo
pongamos los manos a la obra' consigamos
un mejor futuro ahora podemos hacer esto
está dentro de nuestro poder y capacidad
una nueva era de multilateralismo en la
que eeuu buscan mantener su liderazgo a
pesar de la cada vez mayor influencia de
china en el tablero geoestratégico